[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every year approximately 175 million
dollars are spent on constructing and
remodeling biomedical research
facilities in the United States this
amount a significant portion is directed
to laboratories handling and Texas
microorganisms because of the magnitude
of this investment and the hazards to
laboratory personnel it is important
that microbiological safety measures be
incorporated in the design of infectious
disease laboratories these measures are
needed to prevent accidental
occupational infections among laboratory
workers to safeguard the health of the
surrounding community and prevent false
laboratory results due to cross
infection of animals or cultures the
purpose of this film is to describe and
illustrate some of the principle
building features and devices used to
provide effective microbial containment
in determining what safety measures to
incorporate in the design of infectious
disease laboratories much research and
study was necessary for instance we
needed to understand how laboratory
workers become infected and how
microorganisms might escape and spread
within the building or escape to the
surrounding community during the study
it was found that infectious agents are
left loose into a laboratory workers
environment in a manner and in
quantities that cannot always be
detected
however these infectious agents can be
contained by establishing a system of
enclosures or barriers within the
building thus from research and study
the concept of primary and secondary
barriers evolved the enclosures
immediately surrounding infectious
agents are the primary barriers the most
important are the ventilated safety
cabinets other primary barriers include
such items as closed ventilated animal
cages safety centrifuge cups and safety
blender bowls
all serve as the first line of defense
against the escape and possible spread
of infectious microorganisms the
secondary barriers in a laboratory are
the features of the building that
surround the primary barriers these
provide a separation between infectious
areas in the building
and the outside community and between
individual infectious areas within the
same building such features as walls
floors and ceilings ultraviolet air
locks and door barriers and properly
arranged personnel change rooms and
showers are considered secondary
barriers increasingly negative air
pressure as one moves from a clean area
to one of Greater infectious risk can
also be classified as a secondary
barrier furthermore the equipment for
filtering air exhausted from laboratory
rooms comes under this classification as
well as the facilities for treatment of
potentially contaminated liquid wastes
these and other secondary barriers
generally are thought of as providing
supplementary biological containment
serving mainly to prevent the escape of
infectious agents yes then when a
failure occurs in the primary barriers
actually the more effective the primary
barriers are the less need there is for
emphasis on secondary barriers therefore
during the design phase of any
infectious disease laboratory it is both
important and economically necessary to
first determine and select the primary
containment devices to be used early in
the design of any new infectious disease
building definition should be made of
the five functional zones and their
relationship to each other there can be
numerous physical arrangements of these
zones however in this film we will
consider one standardized floor plan as
being typical and showing most of the
recommended containment features the
first functional zone we shall consider
is the clean area
here are located the main entrance to
the building offices conference rooms
and library for administrative work
meetings and similar activities are
carried on also within this area are
transitional rooms through which lab
personnel enter and exit from the
infectious areas of the facility these
consist of a clean change room equipped
with toilets storage space for
laboratory clothing and lockers a non
ventilated airlock with UV lights a
shower room and a contaminated change
room equipped with toilets storage racks
for shoes and the UV shielded bag for
discard clothing in the rear of the
facility is also a clean area with a
transitional airlock this serves to
handle the inward flow of laboratory
supplies into the building and the
outward flow of materials from the
building supplies entering the
infectious areas are passed in through
the UV airlock potentially infectious
material leaving the building is treated
in a double-door steam or ethylene oxide
sterilizer
let's now observe some of the design
features that one might see in the clean
zone personnel usually enter the
facility into a clean area in the front
of the building including the offices
and other support areas pertinent to the
operation of a laboratory clean offices
when located adjacent to the
contaminated zone make possible easy
visual communication through a large
viewing window and minimize personnel
traffic between the two zones for a
communication between the clean and
infectious areas of some laboratories is
often provided by means of speaking
diaphragms a tightly sealed plastic
membrane provides the medium through
which the sound passes treatment of data
sheets and other papers sent from the
contaminated to the clean zones is
accomplished by passing them through an
ultraviolet apparatus where are driven
rollers push the paper through at a
constant rate this assure is adequate
decontamination of each sheet
for treatment of envelopes folders and
books equipment passing locks utilizing
cold sterilization without the lean
oxide are recommended this through the
wall double door chamber allows
sterilization of items in about 12 hours
after which the items can be removed in
the clean zone the passage of personnel
from clean to infectious zone should be
through a clean change room after
changing into lab clothing they pass
through a non ventilated ultraviolet
airlock and then on into a contaminated
change room personnel leaving infectious
owns go through the same change rooms
but in reverse order after returning
their shoes to the storage racks their
lab clothing is discarded into a bag
screened with UV they then take a shower
using a germicidal soap finally they
return to the clean change room passing
first through the airlock in the clean
area at the back of the building there
is another transitional airlock here
supplies and equipment needed for lab
operation are delivered once the outer
door is closed
an electrical interlock allows personnel
in the contaminated area access to the
airlock to remove supplies
returning to our floorplan let's look at
the second functional zone of a typical
facility the lab research area here
infectious microbiological operations
exclusive of animal work are performed
located in this area are the potentially
infectious lab offices the individual
laboratory rooms are usually equipped
with one partial barrier safety cabinet
for work of low to medium risk and a
free-standing single door autoclave at
least one room should contain a gas
tight absolute barrier cabinet system
for performing high hazard operations
with a minimum hazard the system should
terminate in either a double door
autoclave or a germicidal liquid bath
other common features usually found in
this research area are an instrument
room for centrifuges and other operators
and constant temperature rooms for
incubation and refrigeration the hallway
with air pressure positive to the lab
rooms provides additional room to room
separation let's examine some
containment features found in this area
remembering that this is where the bulk
of research and diagnostic work is done
the laboratory zone should be maintained
at an air pressure negative to the clean
zone the lab rooms themselves should
have an air pressure negative to the
adjoining halls and the ventilated
cabinets should be negative to the rooms
ultraviolet fixtures in the ceiling that
are turned on when the room is vacant
will aid in reducing nonspecific
microbial flora a special switch in the
corridor indicates when the light is on
for accidents involving chemicals or
fire emergency showers may be installed
convenient to the research area
particular attention should be given to
the selection of building materials and
methods of construction due to the need
for periodic decontamination paints and
coatings used on walls and other
surfaces must be resistant to steam
disinfectants and frequent washings
walls wall curbing and ceiling should be
free of cracks often a monolithic
covering is used on the floors in order
to facilitate cleaning operations and to
prevent leakage of organisms from the
lab area casework should be sealed to
the wall equipment not sealed to the
wall such as cabinets tables and chairs
may be mounted on wheels to facilitate
decontamination and cleaning lighting
units and other features that penetrate
the barrier walls must be designed so as
to assure adequate physical separation
between the contaminated and clean zones
fluorescent fixtures may be ceiling
mounted and serviced from within the
room or they may be installed above the
ceiling encased in glass and serviced
from a clean attic a good gasket at seal
is necessary to prevent the spread of
contamination from the room into the
Attic where a frequent wash downs of the
area are necessary watertight units such
as these should be employed also o the
electrical outlets in the room should be
watertight to prevent water damage and
internally sealed to prevent leakage of
contamination to provide safe working
conditions for maintenance personnel
electrical panels and utility spaces
should be located in the Queen area
services penetrating the wall should be
sealed airtight at the wall to preserve
the secondary barrier particular
attention should be given the safety
features of walk-in refrigerators and
incubators doors should be equipped with
viewing windows and speaking diaphragms
so that personnel may observe operations
before entering
control switches for electrical outlets
are usually located outside the most
important containment feature in the
infectious disease laboratory is the
ventilated safety cabinet this primary
barrier device isolates the laboratory
workers most potentially infectious
environment although there are many
different cabinet designs there are only
two basic types the absolute barrier
represented by a gas type modular system
and the partial barrier with its open
panel both need to be resistant to a
variety of physical and chemical
materials and therefore our best
constructed of stainless steel let's
consider the partial barrier cabinet in
detail here is an open front type
commonly used for low hazard
manipulations for slightly higher risk
levels glove panels without the gloves
may be attached to the cabinet to
increase the rate of air flow and reduce
spilling and spattering of materials
from the cabinet the cabinet uses a high
efficiency microbial filter for air
leaving the unit the air is ducted to
the nearest exhaust manifold some
partial barrier cabinets are equipped
with front panels with attached arm
length rubber gloves to provide a
greater degree of microbial control with
this cabinet there is a saving in
operating cost since it requires very
little conditioned air as compared to
that needed for the open-face type steam
is one of the desired services and is
used with for mal de to decontaminate
both the inside of the cabinet and it's
exhaust air filter the other basic type
of safety cabinet is the absolute
barrier unit it provides a total
separation between the infectious
working areas and the surrounding
laboratory this cabinet system can serve
as a complete contained laboratory for
the most hazardous microbiological
procedures it is modular in construction
and the end of a
units maybe fitted together in any
desired configuration and length these
gas tight cabinet systems can vary
widely an arrangement maximum
utilization of floor area can be
achieved by double stacking the cabinets
and placing them around the walls others
might be straight-line units that extend
through a wall this particular design
speeds up workflow between two separate
rooms the possible internal features for
absolute barrier systems are almost
limitless
they include interconnecting gas tight
doors back mounted incubators
bottom-mounted lazy susan refrigerators
bottom mounted centrifuges and other
devices
the third functional zone in a standard
facility is the research area for both
small and large infected animals this
usually includes laboratories having
appropriately ventilated cabinets for
inoculation and autopsy and animal rooms
equipped with such isolation equipment
as ventilated cages and UV cage racks in
some instances it may be desirable to
locate in a room adjoining the animal
room aerosol exposure equipment such as
the Henderson apparatus also if not
available elsewhere the animal area
should have an incinerator for disposing
of animal carcasses and a large
autoclave for sterilizing cages and
passing them into a cage washing room in
designing this research area the type
and degree of animal isolation should be
considered early it should always
provide for safe working conditions for
lab personnel and prevent undesired
animal cross infection in those housing
small infected animals the hazard level
is sometimes high enough to require that
protective clothing and respirators be
worn by laboratory personnel in the
animal rooms dust filters should be
installed in the air exhaust ducts to
prevent excessive loading of the
downstream microbial filters with animal
hair and dander the recommended
ventilation rate for the rooms is 15
changes per hour of non recirculated
draught free air of the relative
humidity and temperature appropriate to
the animal species since the walls and
floors of both large and small animal
areas are washed frequently and exposed
to urine and other wastes careful
selection should be made of wall paints
and finishes the nature of some disease
agents in small animals is such that no
special
provisions are needed to prevent animal
across infection or to protect animal
handlers however there are some
infectious agents that require animal
isolation equipment for protecting
personnel one design is a ventilated
cage rack compartment similar to a fume
hood
this unit has sliding doors an inward
flow of air and filtration of exhaust
air by a design modification utilizing a
bolted on plastic panel this compartment
becomes a gas tight absolute barrier
unit it is maintained at a negative
pressure and is supplied with filtered
air the exhaust air is also filtered
here work with animals is done through
attached rubber gloves infected animals
in this system can be handled and then
passed on to an adjoining cabinet for
autopsy or another investigative
procedure in other situations where a
high degree of isolation is required and
where animal to animal separation is
needed infected animals are held in
small individual event elated cages in
some instances instead of closed
ventilated cages animals may be housed
in cages under an ultraviolet barrier
non-portable ventilated animal
compartments have been found effective
in some infectious disease laboratories
each of these horse fall units holds one
or two animal cages and is equipped with
a viewing window and Inlet and outlet
air filters this particular version
utilizes pads of spun glass for air
inlet filters the exhaust air after
filtration goes to a common exhaust
manifold cages of this type must be
decontaminated in place a pressurized
ventilated suit provides another form of
personnel protection during the housing
and handling of infected animals
following its use the attendant must
decontaminate the outside with a
solution of 2% per acetic acid or
another liquid decontaminant
it is convenient to locate small animal
holding rooms close to rooms where
inoculation and autopsy are done with
disease agents of low hazard tabletop
autopsy is permitted in this case the
operator should wear a respirator for a
higher hazard work animal autopsy should
be done in ventilated safety cabinets
where an inward sweep of air prevents
the accidental escape of infectious
aerosol where maximum protection is
required an absolute barrier cabinet
system with attached rubber gloves must
be used this cabinet is equipped with an
autoclave for sterilizing animal
carcasses and other materials removed
from the system large animals usually
are housed and studied in facilities
separate from those for small animals in
this suite the animals are infected with
episodic diseases not transmissible to
man here are located a series of
adjacent rooms and stalls for housing
inoculation surgery autopsy and
incineration of carcasses laboratory
personnel entering the area should pass
through a change room and dress in
proper clothing necessary supplies such
as food and equipment should be brought
in through properly designed airlocks
and stored temporarily in adjacent
storage rooms and feed vestibules
in the design of holding rooms attention
should be given to their flexibility so
as to accommodate various sizes and
species of animals this may be
accomplished by using a room equipped
with removable stanchions and partitions
the room should be constructed to
withstand frequent washing and cleaning
furthermore it should be provided with
vestibules for storage of feed not only
must the individual rooms be cleaned but
the corridor serving them must be hosed
down frequently in some large animal
research areas it is desirable to have a
hydraulically operated tilt table for
surgery
occasionally animal monitoring equipment
also is provided after an autopsy
provision should be made for
transporting the carcass here a large
pan supported from a monorail is used to
carry the carcass through an airlock to
the incinerator when the incinerator is
part of the infectious area the firebox
should be maintained at negative air
pressure to the room in order to prevent
blowback of contaminated materials the
fourth zone in a lab facility is
designated as laboratory support this is
best located outside the contaminated
research areas and includes rooms for
washing and sterilizing glassware and
animal cages preparing Culture Media
storing glassware and animal cages and
repairing various laboratory items a
more detailed look suggests but due to
the many heat generating devices and
odor producing procedures in this area
careful attention should be given to the
design of the ventilation system also
because of a great amount of water
involved in washing operations floors
walls and other surfaces should be
resistant to moisture in glass washing
non-contaminated glassware may be
processed either in a tunnel type
machine that allows for an automatic
continuous flow of items or a batch type
washing unit for small amounts the
sterilization equipment needed in lab
support consists principally of dry heat
ovens and steam sterilizers in the cage
washing room small animal cages may be
processed in a continuous flow tunnel
type machine where larger units are
processed a batch type washer with
multiple or rotating spray heads often
is used when the cage debris contains
highly infectious organisms the cage
with its debris should always be
sterilized before it enters the lab
support area another lab support
activity is the preparation of Culture
Media the room for this should have a
controlled movement of filtered supply
air during the pouring of the plates and
the preparation of other sterile media
to limit the ingress of microorganisms
air in the room always should be
maintained at positive pressure to the
other lab support rooms an adequate
storage room should be provided for
glassware animal cages and other
equipment as well as a small machine and
glass repair shop
the fifth functional zone in the lab
facility provides engineering support
included here are the necessary pipes
ducts pumps blowers and filters as well
as the liquid waste treatment system and
the bulk of the air handling system
special engineering arrangement should
maintain the integrity of the secondary
barrier when penetration of the wall is
made by pipes wires and ducts regardless
of whether the engineering zone is
located on the same or a different level
from the other functional zones as much
of the engineering support area as
possible should be located outside the
contaminated zone possibly on the
grounds adjacent to the building or in
the basement or attic of the facility
because of the large amount of
engineering equipment needed more than
half a total building area is sometimes
required the most important engineering
functions are air handling and
ventilation often involving nearly 50%
of the cost of the laboratory building
one vital consideration is the need to
locate the air intake grill upwind to
the exhaust stack there should be
adequate physical separation between
both to prevent cross-contamination in
engineering support air ducts going to
each room in the infectious zone should
deliver non recirculating filtered and
conditioned air in virus labs Inlet air
is often passed through outra high
efficiency filters these ducts need not
be of airtight construction exhaust air
ducts coming from the infectious zone
must be airtight however to assure no
leakage of infectious microorganisms
before air reaches the exhaust filter
plenum galvanized ducts with taped epoxy
coated joints have been found
satisfactory they exhaust air plenums in
a building are often designed to serve
several laboratory rooms of about the
same hazard level they may be equipped
either with high-efficiency spun glass
matze or with ultra-high efficiency
units for filtering air discharge from
the rooms since the filters in a plenum
must be changed periodically provisions
must be made for decontaminating both
the filters and the plenum itself before
opening the unit a mixture of steam and
formaldehyde is used as the
decontaminating material the facility's
ventilation system should provide an
interlock between the exhaust and
supplied Lords this is to prevent
pressurization of the infectious zones
in case the exhaust blower fails a
pneumatic control system senses the air
pressure in each room and assures
correct air balance throughout the
laboratory exhaust air from aerosol
chambers and other high hazard equipment
should pass through welded pipelines to
an incinerator electrically operated
units are both practical and efficient
for quantities of up to 100 cubic feet a
minute this unit and the ones that
follow should be preceded by a microbial
filter as a fail-safe device for larger
volumes of air gas or oil fired
incinerators may be used
with this oil-fired unit a pall stack
serves to discharge the air at a
substantial distance above the building
an important part of an engineering
support zone is the central control
board here readouts of all systems in
the area can be readily monitored by
engineering personnel such board should
have visual and audible alarms that will
automatically signal the failure of any
part of the system another important
item is the standby electrical generator
it is used in the event commercial power
supply is interrupted
sometimes the units are mounted in
trailers to provide easy portability in
some laboratories facilities must be
provided for treating contaminated
liquid wastes to basic systems are
employed the batch and the continuous
flow the batch system shown here is used
to collect waste from infected animal
areas liquids flow by gravity to the
tank where they are sterilized by adding
steam and holding for a period of time
the piping should have welded joints to
assure no possibility of leakage note
that a concrete curb has been provided
to contain the liquid in the event of a
rupture in the system there are larger
volumes of waste are produced multiple
batch treatment tanks are used here is a
continuous flow arrangement which
utilizes steam to raise the liquid to a
proper temperature the waste flows
through a series of retention tubes and
is cooled through a heat exchanger
before being discharged all such systems
can be monitored and controlled from a
central board where flow Arrangements
waste volumes treatment times and
temperatures are visually indicated this
film has emphasized the concepts of the
primary barrier and the secondary
barrier in designing a laboratory for
the study of infectious disease these
concepts apply to the five functional
zones namely the clean the laboratory
research the animal research the
laboratory support and
engineering zones the film has given
examples of how various operating
laboratories have used these concepts
although there is no complete substitute
for careful training and good
microbiological technique by a
knowledgeable laboratory supervisor
sooner or later a point may be reached
in the experimentation when there is
need for a building and equipment with
emphasis upon protection for the
investigator the experiment and the
public the film has served its purpose
if it provides significant assistance to
those persons responsible for the design
construction and operation of
laboratories for the study of infectious
disease